[Musique]
mais les vous de vos affaires ce soir il
ya de plus en plus de canadiens qui se
disent victimes de tentatives de fraudes
le problème se répand plus vite au
canada qu'ailleurs randria web ayant un
lien avec le déconfinement je vais vous
expliquer tout ça je veux présenter les
données de la firme de surveillance du
credit crunch union qui a fait un bilan
mondial pour le deuxième trimestre et
oui on observe que les tentatives de
fraude se multiplient un peu partout ça
va grimper en nombre d'à peu près 16 et
demi pour cent au cours du deuxième
trimestre seulement et comme si on
pouvait le voir beaucoup plus rapidement
au canada presque 45% et le lien avec le
déconfinement c'est qu'ici peut-être un
peu plus qu'ailleurs il ya eu donc
réouverture dans certains secteurs
ça crie tout un brouhaha quand on est
occupé à gérer réouverture logistique il
ya plus de fraude qui sont difficiles à
déceler si vous voulez c'est la raison
pour laquelle sa touche et le canada et
certains secteurs en particulier entre
autres le jeu en ligne les tentatives de
froment aux de 210% on tente de vendre
l'argent virtuel à utiliser dans votre
jeu en lien avec la réouverture de
l'industrie des voyages et des loisirs
hausse de 216% des tentatives de fraude
commerce de détail en progression 139%
et dans les services financiers c'est
une offre encore de 30% mais c'est moins
spectaculaire que ce qu'on a vu au cours
des derniers mois yat-il encore beaucoup
de tentatives de ford en lien direct
avec la pandémie il y en a encore et pas
mal en fait à peu près
une tentative de fraude sur trois à
l'échelle mondiale ses 36 % des
tentatives de fraudes qui ont un lien
direct avec la copine même pourcentage
pour le canada et s'apprend quelle forme
ces tentatives de fraude d'encore une
fois le hameçonnage on vous envoie un
courriel ou entente avec un thème
coville où on tente de vous soutirer des
informations personnelles c'est à peu
près le tiers de toutes les tentatives
de fraude 31% pour les cartes de crédit
de 10 7% le vol d'identité 14% fraude
d'expédition sont en progression ça on
vous envoie quelque chose que vous
n'avez jamais commandé et 13 pour cent
de ses tentatives de fraude en lien
direct avec l'aide financière les
chèques qui sont envoyés par le
gouvernement fédéral entre autres merci
beaucoup andré vous en prie pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez vous sur
la chaîne ici et redit